I admit I do sympathize a little with
Dylan Mulvaney because I too was once an
impressionable theater kid and who knows
what could have happened to me if I was
cast into rent on Broadway in my wayward
youth I sympathize with Bill Mulberry
because I was a theater kid let's answer
and I'll one two three
this is the game that you have all been
waiting for that I have all been waiting
for a game featuring one of my absolute
favorite people
in the entire daily wire universe that
would be my friend Brett Cooper before
we get into it though have you ever
wondered what it's like to trade places
with me you probably are now I'm sure
you would love to sit opposite Fred
Cooper well you can you can't hang out
with Brett but you can get yes or no the
game that's right dailywire.com shop we
ordered some of these games maybe six
months ago and we kind of just missed
Christmas and it sold out immediately
they're selling like lightning pre-order
yours now or you will miss out again the
alleywire.com
shop the very greatest Arty game on
planet Earth
and I feel this is the very greatest
episode we've ever done because Brett
you're here I'm so excited we've been
trying to do this we obviously could not
play this game before you were 21.
exactly so now you're gonna have to
drink for the two of us because you know
as a mackerel snapping papist one gives
up something for Lent I've never done it
before in my whole life but this year
I'm giving up booze so I'll be drinking
what looks like a cosmo it is in fact a
strawberry flavored salt or something I
was gonna say is this like pink lemonade
you know it's a strawberry lemonade and
you are drinking a room temperature gin
is that right no no I'm drinking
I'm drinking a drink of choice
can I be really gross are you just
digging it out
there you are
you know it just can't be
that's the stuff ladies first okay let's
begin
it's alcohol in my hands now all right
on average a sober female driver is more
dangerous than a drunk male driver
so you you figure out what I'm going to
say and yeah
more dangerous than it
one two three
I'm afraid you got that wrong Brett
it's obviously this is not just my
opinion by the way okay sweet little
Elisa now if we're calling an Uber or
something okay and a female driver pops
up she will be inclined to cancel
because she because they missed the exit
Okay I mean it's very like the series of
other female drivers
I get it but also you have to bring up
Insurance like why is Insurance higher
for like teen boys versus teams yeah
well but I guess maybe as they age
do I just do we just drink whenever
basically that's how I could okay
uh that's that's true it's also because
our society is very anti-patriarchal yep
you know punishes the boys but yes while
it is true that maybe 21 year old men
are a little more rambunctious yes in
the long run
when you hit 40 as a lady it just gets
yeah the thing about stereotypes I
figured out Brett yeah yeah they're all
completely true that makes sense
all right shall we uh now I go okay
if women can wear makeup in their dating
profiles men should be able to lie about
their height and income
okay women can wear makeup men should be
able to lie about their height and
income
wrong again what no they shouldn't have
mentioned it you should never lie I
don't think I don't think that make I
mean I know that you don't wear makeup
you sort of wake up naturally but some
women do wear makeup and it's not a lie
to wear makeup it is it accentuates I
would say maybe underlying Beauty
I I think that some women take it so far
maybe I was answering in the context of
like how I see makeup where it's I don't
wear a lot unless I'm on camera but even
that is like I look the same guys
um but there are some people I feel
totally different you can completely
like the way that people Contour their
face look you look like a totally
different person with that I'm like okay
that's like disingenuous I always find
women who wear a lot of makeup yeah I
find it doesn't make them look better
even if they're a kind of plain Jane
looking yeah because I like I don't know
I I am attracted to reality I like
reality more than fantasy and so if I
see a nice girl who is you know just
confident and naturally beautiful in
whatever way she is I'm going to find
that much more attractive than some
person who's you know had plastic
surgery to look like a Kardashian or
something but it's interesting how many
women go to such lengths to completely
like change everything about themselves
whether it be like with the plastic
surgery I mean that new thing if you've
seen like the buccal fat surgery
they're sucking fat out of your cheeks
to make you
oh that looks like that yeah so like so
I have like a Perpetual like a duck face
like going to those kinds of like
ridiculous links and then all the caked
on makeup yeah
oh yeah yeah and the fake eyelashes that
kind of look like caterpillars all of
that where it's like you're going to
such lengths and then you wonder why
guys like
say like oh like no girl looks like her
dating profile like this is so crazy
like I just want her to be natural but
then women have gone so far it's very
weird but you got it right I did I don't
think that men should lie but I also
think women need to stop editing their
photos they need to stop taking on
makeup it's better for your skin too
yeah the other thing I mean maybe you'll
say yes it does matter but
you're very successful in your own right
would it really matter if a guy puffed
up his salary on a dating profile
maybe it would I don't know people comes
down to integrity
but also you know when dating profiles
don't really talk about their salary
um
if it was height
yeah if you're just kind of like I'm a
half an inch taller that's fine five
foot I'm five foot two and three
quarters but I say six feet just Round
Up Just round up that's
I round up to six four actually well
that's impressive good for you yeah
yeah but if it's like you're five seven
and you're saying you're six but it's
like okay now you're just catfishing
yeah
um
but it's so difficult because on many
dating profiles it's so General so it's
like a lot of these statements you can't
really tell me until you actually talk
to the person but so many people on
dating apps they don't actually go on
dates that's the thing they'll talk for
months because it's a game what yes oh
no people don't go on dates from dating
apps very few of them do you sit around
because it's a game you swipe you get
the instant gratification you might talk
so someone likes me someone thinks I'm
cute yes exactly you talk and you'll
never meet up and I have friends that
are you know we'll try to you know oh I
want to go out with this guy or whatever
and they'll try to make it happen with
like in three to four days because
obviously you don't want to go out with
somebody maybe he's a serial killer yeah
um but yeah that's I I don't remember
what the stats are but it's like it'll
be weeks or months before they even get
around to going out I just missed dating
apps I just missed it sweet little Elise
and I got back together right okay we're
coming up so I I missed I never was on
one yeah I have friends who've done them
all the time
to get me to text my wife back to get me
to text my employers to get me to text
myself to get to text you back to really
to text my dear friends I it takes days
and days and days yeah and I think
people now for recreation will go on to
just text strangers for months with no
point other than that maybe additional
whatsoever wow so because of that I
think a lot of people are very relaxed
with what they put on there because
those conversations very rarely have any
kind of substance and so it's like oh
you and often like I was on a podcast
recently and the guy asked me to like
look at his profile like oh would you
rate it or something like that and I've
had my guy friends like do very similar
things no my girlfriends too and it's
all very very general and when I look at
them I'm like why would you not you know
put everything out there basically and
like talk about your non-negotiables
like say what you're actually looking
for I saw this girl on Tick Tock who did
this whole video basically raging doing
like that angry feminist rant about this
guy and she posted their conversation
and he wrote back oh you're so beautiful
she said oh my God thank you and he said
could I ask you you know what you're
looking for and her response was
I don't really know I'm just kind of
figuring things out and so he writes
back and says Okay I want to be up front
I travel a lot for work I'm really not
sure if I want something serious right
now I'm really just looking for like
Friends with Benefits maybe if it like
moves in somebody's being honest he's
being upfront he's on the app he's like
hi I'm a dirt bag yeah I just want to
please my body exactly and like I don't
I want to use you as an instrument for
my own body yes exactly but he asked she
said I don't really care and so she he
responded honestly and then she flips
out at him and goes how dare you think
that 'll do this like I'm looking for
something serious I would never like go
down to that like level yeah and be
honest you can't play both sides of it
you can't play games and expect men not
to be playing games it's a constant
double standard and so I like that
though the conclusion being women might
not know what they want yeah but they
definitely know what they don't want
yeah that is very true with women but
anyway the apps are so gainy and if you
actually want to use it properly Dennis
Breakers talked about this a lot and
he's talked to me about it when I was
still living in LA and he's actually a
big advocate for dating apps
Dennis is a player you know Dennis just
wants everybody to get married with the
stove yeah right well I remember when I
was at prageru he was like constantly
trying to match fake people if you were
like a 20 year old whatever
let me find you somebody like let me go
anybody in my community but we were
talking about dating apps and I was kind
of like oh you know they're so stupid he
was like no especially if you were in
like a liberal area he said this is the
best way to weed everybody out but the
caveat is that you have to be
intentional you have to actually put
your religion you can't be like Oh I'm a
moderate if you're actually conservative
no just say it because then the people
who are going to be angry at you and are
gonna hate you you're not wasting your
time you're not wasting their time
you're the people that are going to
actively be interested are like oh this
is great you're being out there get on
the dating app yes yes swipe right yeah
I'm Dennis Price okay anyway so we're
moving on here we go okay hmm
technically I know more about pop
culture than you
so I'm answering as me and you're
answering as you well no no I'm
answering for you right yeah right right
you're you're answering as if to say I
Michael Knowles know more about pop
culture than you right oh okay I think
so and you're moving that one oh wait oh
so now we're getting it right
I Michael Knowles yeah and I'm answering
I Brett Cooper
take you Michael Knowles to be my
lawfully winner here we are
true
it's true obviously what I don't the
most modern musician I listen to is Van
Morrison
no you listen to my
mileage and Miley that's true I really
dug that Miley song I think we listened
to the rest of her album no I thought it
was a single and it was a whole album
well it was a single in May but that's
one of the songs it's not it's kind of
is it Chef first three songs yeah great
the rest of them I was like she started
randomly talking in the middle of the
song so I was like I'm not here to
listen to you talk yeah with your like
smoker voice no it's I like I mean it's
a sultry voice but I've always been Pro
Miley since Party in the USA I really
liked that and this whole thing about
you know you could have had flowers yeah
I don't need you to hold my hand or
whatever yeah I like it it's a good it's
a jazzy kind of 70s funky thing yeah and
I I and it's and it shows how a misery
inducing modern uh and I don't think
that what I liked about it was that it
was not like man shaming it was just
saying hey I can you know
she's talking about the things that a
woman would want and say you know if
you're not going to give those to me
I'll find them somewhere else it's not
about like I hate you it's more about
her which I appreciate because most
things modern feminist culture are
always like working at the men but I
found it ironic too because she's saying
like I can buy myself flowers I can it's
like no like you can but it's not the
same thing obviously and you're
presenting it okay I'm up
Helen Keller was faking oh my God
okay no I've got an answer to this okay
one team and I debate this all the time
one two three
no really no she wasn't faking it yeah
the people around her certainly were
faking because I think that she's real
you think that she's a deaf dumb blind
woman who flew an airplane that's what
you're saying he said she flew an
airplane
yeah and like she also didn't she had
this special friend who
Helen Keller would communicate with the
Friend by like hand massages or
something and then a friend would just
yeah the way that you yes yeah and then
the friend would just magically
interpret this and Helen Keller wrote
all these books and found an airplane or
whatever and but but then when the
friend died or went away or something
then that was then Helen Keller chose
not to write any more books or fly any
more airplanes I don't know it just I'm
not
airplane
I do think that somebody
obviously can exist to you know is blind
and deaf not gonna think but I like I
loved the miracle worker that play I've
only seen jokes about like I've only
seen the South Park about the Miracle
Works so good the play is fantastic yeah
and I mean and her books are great I do
believe
the cheese right I don't know the extent
of the stories that they've told about
her yeah I mean she's a woman yeah I do
believe that she could learn that stuff
though because I know that there is sign
language that you can do it's a
different kind of sign language but it's
just done in the poem yeah but maybe I
don't know maybe it was just like that
person was sort of crutch but maybe they
you know over blew it obviously because
now she was making a bunch of money yeah
I I'm not definitively saying it was all
fake news we should have questions I
think it's fair to like we live in a
world right now where they told us that
an experimental drug would stop us from
getting a cough that was the worst
plague in human history and it you know
and that turned out to be a little
what am I allowed to say in like a
little dubious so I'm just a little I
just have questions for obviously the
Keller writes yes if it's not true
at least it makes a good story
I think that sums up my feelings
I still appreciate the play
eyes
I've never had to call in sick to work
the day after my 21st birthday
I'm just talking about this okay so I'm
answering
um so it's about me or wait so I'm
answering is it there's a question about
me no it's about anybody not everything
is about you Brad just most things all
right thank you no so you're answering
it as me I'm Michael Nelson I've already
fall into work sick day after my 21st
birthday
you're a bit of a crazy guy
I was but I was also irresponsible and
didn't have a job when I was twins
and you my dear
should I tell the story I think so well
guys my birthday is obviously October
12th I started working here when I was
20 I just turned 20 actually and I got
my offer
um
and so I spent the whole year here not
drinking and having apple juice and the
champagne flutes whatever daily wire
would do special events you were trying
to get me to come on yes and no
um but no so my 21st birthday I had like
four different things planned I even had
a cabin trip planned with Madison you
know with a bunch of our friends we're
gonna go up to Asheville
um and it was going to be a great time
and I have never had the best luck with
birthdays something always happens I
don't know what it is but I'm like the
quintessential and maybe this is the
zoom we're in me I was crying on my
birthday and you never have a good time
prior tears of joy oh no no no no no
just stress constantly yes
um one time I think this is my 17th
birthday I had two midterms on my
birthday so I took one was my Spanish
midterms the worst midterm I ever took
when my car sobbed yes and then my mom
was dealing with like a health thing
with my brother and so I sat at home in
Burbank on my porch and ate Domino's
Pizza and cried again it was great
anyway so half of that sounds nice yeah
it was Solace
um but anyway so I just you know I was
really hopeful about this I was like
living in a new city of a great job of
great friends here and I get sick I get
the flu
um you got the flu I got the flip I
actually did so we um I had a concert
that I was supposed to go to
that night it was uh the wildlife and
floor two of my favorite bands oh yeah
I'm a huge I like them before they got
popular so I'm sure before they sold out
in one Main Street exactly oh they're
not even mainstream though yeah no well
I'm saying you know even back when they
were nothing
and they were in there yeah you were a
big fan
um no and so I like left that concert in
the middle because my throat was hurting
so bad I didn't have a single drink on
my 21st birthday like literally not a
single one I went to dinner in East did
not get a single drink went to this
concert I drank a chugged water and then
the next day I actually saw Scotty at
that concert she can attest to that yeah
there she is yeah I got an alibi I do
clever girl and then I canceled the
cabin trip because I was so sick and
then I got Madison sick the only reason
that I'm inclined to possibly believe
the story is
people always say well your 21st
birthday did you go crazy but I think
you know
at least for me was it wasn't my first
rodeo when I turned 21 and so at a
certain point you're like well I've kind
of been doing this for a while I don't
actually like the charm yeah I have said
it before and I've said it publicly I
had more fun before I turned 21. yeah
and then I it hit and I literally did
not drink for the two months after my
21st birthday because I was like
okay
for men wearing loafers without socks is
a lot like wearing Beats by Dre
headphones as a woman both are things
you experiment with in college and are
sort of a rite of passage for basic
white people however unlike the loafers
you can easily clean headphones so they
are better
did your research wow
so all right so so the headphones the
the punch line here is Beats by Dre are
better than sockless loafers and that
they're both basic and not cool yeah
that's all part of the premise I mean I
think basic white people stuff can be
perfectly fine I like LL Bean you know
yeah
is better than like pastel polo shirts
um
okay so the Beats By Dre are better than
sockless loafers
yeah nowhere
okay you wanna no cyclist low first I
can't talk with loafers really hey what
I ate it I just did Elijah were you guys
watching my all access they must have
known I talked about yesterday no so
listen I know that I know that you wear
socks and slippers of course I I I
dolled myself up for you did he work
Black Ops see that's see that's that's
the best but here my thing is with the
loafers that you wear I think it's more
acceptable when men wear these loafers
with the tie like the ones that the
tassel loafers yeah well no no no with
the laces with the laces like Oxford
juice yes okay whatever a loafer is sort
of defined by a black slide okay
it's more so I still think that's not
great if it's not Springtime and you're
not at a beach wedding it's like put on
the socks
um but if it's an Oxford why do men wear
those without socks do those yes that's
insane they do well that's insane it's
very uncomfortable yeah I'm sure I'm
like I don't want to see your ankles
cover them up yeah
yeah I don't know I'm like I'm like a
principal telling people like cover up
like telling Girls cover up your
shoulders telling them like cover up
here telling waspy men that hey put
those ankles literally get yourself down
to the country club put on some damn
socks put on some socks yeah okay and I
think the other part of this punch line
is that my headphones that I wore on the
show are Beats well that I knew yeah but
that's you know it's fine for an age but
the thing is a a waspy man and a wasp
identifying man of any race culture or
background can wear sockless loafers or
let's include maybe Topsiders from truly
from six months old until his dying day
that's true it is it's Timeless it's
Timeless you know I rocked the Topsiders
I love Sperry Top ciders yeah not
anymore but I mean like my family's big
and sailing so I had a lot of votes how
did I I could see that I could you exude
a kind of sailing Vibe my whole family
does it's the one thing we all do wow
competitively yeah competitively because
I like the idea of the William F Buckley
Jr version of sailing the big votes yeah
you go out you kind of wear a silly
sweater yeah I think he would
occasionally puff a little Haitian
oregano oh no we're in like full body
like all-weather suits wow like hanging
out the side of boats my brothers and I
did that and then my dad also competed
and then my mom she was more of the like
relaxing her first husband would like
cruise around and she would be there
with like drinks and food you're like
the conservative answer to Greta
thunberg you know there's Saint Greta
there in that boat in the middle of the
ocean yeah I assume helicopters dropping
caviar yeah and then there's you having
a great time not crying about it
um
decriminalizing prostitution would be
more problematic for society than
decriminalizing schedule one drugs such
as weed LSD and mushrooms
no wait would be more problematic so
it's worse to decriminalize
prostitution
let's just see what happens
I don't know whether you're more
anti-drug or more anti-prostitute
I'm not advocating either
in an impossible situation but if if I
had to choose one to decriminalize
hookers or or drugs yep I would I would
choose the hookers because okay one it's
much more traditional world's old
profession yep and uh
two both Saint Augustine and St Thomas
Aquinas make arguments not for the
legalization of prostitution okay but
arguments against further outlawing
prostitution because uh they say Saint
Augustine says and then uh Saint Thomas
Aquinas reiterates this that it
if there is not this outlet that is
tolerated or if it's further clamped
down society would be so convulsed by
lust that you would have far worse
outcomes uh for people interesting and
more of sexual violence that sort of
thing and now that's the calculations
change a little bit today because
there's porn everywhere uh but but if I
had to tolerate one of those evils
whereas when it comes to LSD and all
these hippie drugs that turns every
every person from a normal person to a
huge lid yeah I've never seen it go the
other direction one of my really good
friends really yeah you sure yes are you
sure very sure for his like 23rd
birthday his like request for me was
just to like
he because I was like what do you want
to do and he was like actually I just
want to like hang out and like trip and
I said well I'm not gonna do that yeah
but if you want me to like hang around
and like bring you food or whatever
um but his big like shroom trip was him
realizing that like the elites are all
out to get us and he was like you're all
right like the government it's like
awful in there you know they're
conspiring against us and I was like
okay because that's usually been the
case that's interesting yeah I had a
friend this is the only non-disastrous
psychedelic story ever a buddy of mine
took mushrooms and was in Washington DC
and he looked at he was on the marble
monuments and he looked down so he said
oh what are those ants doing crawling
around on the marble but it wasn't
really ants yeah it was the black and
white of the marbles it was the black of
the marble and he was experiencing this
as an animate reality but then said no
no this is just the pigment of the stone
which is inanimate
but then because he was super high he
realized no it actually just was ants so
and then he sobered up and you know we
went on with our day yeah but the
takeaway from that is that
he could experience metaphor he was
experiencing a blurring of the literal
and the figurative which I think is very
important because I don't believe in
anything is being merely literal I think
this is a semiotic world and everything
has meaning so that was one thing but he
didn't really get that into the
Psychedelic stuff yeah my other friends
have gotten into it they they always
come to the same conclusion they say no
man I was so stressed and and then I ate
a bunch of mushrooms and a bunch of
bathtub acid and then I realized it was
cool gave me peace because I realized
man
I don't need to worry about like sin and
guilt and stuff I don't you know some of
them believe me I saw these little like
beings it was like aliens almost and
they it kind of showed me man there's
another dimension I don't need to worry
about Sin and which is not a positive
outcome yeah it's like hey bro do you
know who would try to convince you not
to worry about Sin
demons that's those little weird alien
things you saw yeah did you hear about
my brother's experience yeah okay so my
brother did a ton of drugs so there's
like he's like the primary reason that I
became very very anti-drug and started
with weed and then it's basically done
everything under the sun right but he is
now has drug-induced schizophrenia like
very very very serious but the things
that he sees in his trips they are all
like devilish like demons like literal
like demons on his shoulder that tell
him that like he like caused the
destruction of our family like all of
this stuff like it is truly like you are
like going to hell and like that kind of
stuff and it's like
how was this and then he kept doing it
like oh I you know maybe it'll be better
let me like try something else let me
try another hallucinogenic and I'm like
it's obviously not but no that's my one
friend is the only time that I've seen
it in the positive I have very good my
best friend actually
has experimented with a lot of it who
Publix publicly will say like I think
everybody should like trip once in their
life and I'm like oh he was like no I'm
good man I love you yeah uh am I up yes
okay right I don't I don't know I don't
know yeah I have better hair
huh
wait I have better hair so you're
answering is me I'm answering issue
I think you know what's good for you
come on
give a little turn oh yeah let me give
you a full
I will say your hairs
yep
I guess we'll let the audience decide
do you use Jeremy's Razor's hair
products I actually do I do I do I do
very high priority hair products they
are I but I've had this and they're like
quite clean too yes no they're super no
seed oils it's all made of beef Tallow I
don't really know much about this no but
they don't have any parfum in them or
anything like that I hate parfumen I
love cardamom but I hate
profitables I don't use the uh the beef
Tallow deodorant but you do but I use
the salt crystal as a deodorant that's
even crunchier I know it is but I do use
the beef towel moisturizer but I did
which you gave me yes
Michaela Peterson though she is like
very obviously she has her autoimming me
and stuff so she's like allergic to a
lot of things but she had a recent
breakout due to her shampoo so she uses
beef towel shampoo so what you were
saying was that you actually can you can
buy it on Etsy it's like a bar of beef
yeah this is the thing I never got into
fad diets or anything Elisa convinced me
seed oils made by the same demons that
you see on mushrooms and beef Tallow
cures everything beef tap the answer to
all of the things because it's going
back to something that's natural it's
like we have all of these
remedies it's like when you go on to
Skin Care
five different products that all do
different things they all have different
chemicals different but they're kind of
like weird concoctions of the same thing
and you buy all of them thinking they're
all going to be effects but you're
really just like putting more chemicals
on your face it's like why do we need
all of that when there are very simple
Solutions like why is it that men that
my brother can wash his face with a bar
of Dove soap and have clearer skin than
me you're right right and I've like used
every I had like a dermatologist from
the time that I was you know eight years
old because child actors obviously can't
show a single pimple pimples can't have
a single whatever and I've had like
worse skin than him and all he does is
just like Splash Water the Dove soap or
now even forgetting that I'm just gonna
start walking up in a field a lot of
cows around Nashville it's going to
slice off some fat but on my face throw
it back to the cow I got Brandon Tatum's
wife on it too did you try to get some
for Candace yeah yeah I'm really into it
I the answer to all of life's ills is be
fat yeah okay true well it's my turn oh
it's your turn
as a rule women are more shallow than
men
[Music]
no no I don't think so they're different
they're differently shallow maybe that's
a better way to put up but they're women
are are deeper than men in certain
respects they're women are more
realistic they're more emotional I think
like they have more emotional depth yeah
they're certainly more sensitivity yeah
but they're I think they're also more
grounded people think of men you know as
being there were the grounded ones and
women are taking place of fancy that's
not true men are Lord Byron going off to
fight a revolution in the middle of
Greece or something men are The Poets
right men are are the ones who write
love sonnets and you know have a boom
box yes and and women are just like man
Mac are you sure really I think you kind
of added you know and and so women are
are much
deeper and more grounded in that way
yeah but I think men tend to
probe more deeply into the the
into abstraction yeah I feel like these
days
I see more commonly men calling out
women's shallow behavior and maybe it's
because women have become more shallow
and we can go back to the whole like
dating thing of you know only caring
about you know fashion and their hair
and their makeup and that kind of thing
and I think that might be because we've
deviated from these Traditional Values
and traditional roles where women had
really important you know roles in the
home and they took those very seriously
and now it's kind of like I mean you
look at you know what you were talking
about on whatever podcast I was watching
you know Isabel Brown's episode last
night where you know they're so
flippantly just being like Oh actually
no it wasn't Israel Brown's was another
clip that I saw from whatever but this
guy was like you know if I want to marry
a woman I'm going to make her my wife
and this girl was like flipping out but
he was saying I'm gonna make you like my
wife or whatever she was like no your
girlfriend's like she's just going to
want to go to the club and like have
nice dresses and he was like no I'm not
gonna marry somebody like that of course
but that kind of you know image of women
these days and kind of that stereotype
that comes with it I would think that
they've become more shallow but when you
go back to those more traditional roles
where you have a very very serious job
in the home and you have like a very
like women took themselves very
seriously and what they were like
designed to do yeah that seems less
shallow yeah I don't know and I don't
run my home at all I don't know I don't
know what my bills are I don't know if
I've ever paid any of my bills in the
home and uh so that you know that's a
real grounding but you're you're right
if if a woman follows feminism then that
will make her more shallow because
feminism says that the only way for a
woman to have any value is to pretend to
be a man yeah and I got news for those
ladies they ain't never going to be as
good a man as I am nope they're not I'm
not saying I'm the greatest man in the
world he's trying he's going the other
yeah it's crazy
the most prominent woman in America is a
huge dude I would say though like I
think about you know different
Industries yeah and being in the acting
world and I don't know how it was ignore
time at Yale and like that sort of thing
but people in Hollywood
it's like they're so shallow it's like
why do you care more about your skincare
than I do why do you care more about
your hair oh I can't do this it's gonna
whatever I'm like oh my god did you ever
work in New York as an actress when I
was very young because I mean like eight
to ten years okay yeah because the this
was always considered one of the big
differences in New York and L.A yeah or
the people were just serious in general
yeah right everybody in New York tends
to be more serious and especially in the
theater in New York because you're
you're in an actor's craft there where
it's you know you're following a story
beginning to end every night whereas I I
remember when I got out to LA one of the
acting teachers in New York kind of
legendary guy was 92 he trained
everybody don't go to La yeah la is lies
it's shallow and then you get there and
everyone is super hot yeah every there
is a lot more work because there's all
this film stuff it's all fake too it's
all fake it's less about like I remember
I would do I had a bunch of different
acting teachers in L.A and I had like
the film act teachers yeah because it's
not like serious it's like you're on and
then I'll call it Phil it's like you're
on camera yeah it's like don't blink
yeah exactly
um and then I had my like more theater
oriented it was so different because
with the on camera ones it was like all
right so when you go into your audition
you want to basically trick them into
thinking that you're the role so dress
this way you know go in as the character
and with like the New York t-shirts that
I had that were more like theater based
it was like all right obviously you are
still Michael Knowles I'm still Brett
Cooper you're in the given circumstances
which is what acting should be but I was
like you don't care like you could show
up in sweatpants and absolutely crush it
they'd be like oh that's so anything
yeah yeah um but true I mean I think
that I guess yeah that's an important
distinction the LA actor guys yeah but I
mean the women are dressed as shallow
but I think that's true differently so
the chat GPT danger and doomsday hype is
more clever marketing than any real risk
of it being evil or
detrimentally sentient
evil or detrimentary sentient okay
okay yeah it's made up it's not that
dangerous one two three
that's super Dave yeah I hate it it's
it's I hate AI it's I know we were
talking about demons earlier and I'm not
saying it's always demons not like the
guy in the History Channel so it's yeah
but
there's weird demon stuff with Chachi B
today yeah is it what is it a demon or
an angel is uh pure intellect right and
disembodied intellect and what is chat
gbt a simulacrum of yeah a disembodied
intellect and you get really did you
read about the AI demon no loab no long
story short this AI engineer artist
person found a demon so but I look at it
and people think oh it's this very very
cool like almost non-biased like just
technology no you it's not non-biased
there's obviously like a programmer back
there creating all of the stuff and I do
think that it has the potential maybe to
like take on a mind of its own in some
way but it has to start from somewhere
oh yeah and I did a whole episode where
I was asking a different prompts and if
you ask it to you know write a speech in
the voice of Kamala Harris it will if
you say you know would you do something
on the voice of Brett Cooper or bench
pair it's like no those are like we
don't do hateful whatever I did um I
said can you tell me about or write
about the dangers of minor retracted
persons or something like that and they
said no these are protected class and
they said like this is something we're
like trying to gave it like a disclaimer
so we will not respond because we don't
understand minor attracted persons and
psychologists think that this is you
know we need to understand them and
respect them and obviously it's
different than pedophilia and it's like
no it still has a bias also it is
a different name and I think that it is
objectively cool that we have been able
the technology has gone this far and I
am you know it's a great job for the
people who did it it's like cool look
how high that Tower of Babel got wow
good job wow amazing like let's stop
there's like a point anyway and I I
think that it's really really have you
seen the videos that they've done of us
where they like use AI to change the
things that we've said oh yeah and some
of them are really funny but it's like
Ben Trump Joe Rogan and Peterson playing
Minecraft together and that kind of
thing but then it's you know people are
so dumb and they get duped by headlines
every single day now oh yeah and imagine
you know we're going into this you know
election cycle
and you can't tell what is AI or not
there are so many idiots in the world
and I say that with like the kindness of
my heart but I mean maybe it's maybe it
is it's not the right word but people
who
to give them the benefit of the doubt
don't have a lot of time you're not
interested or just kind of watching news
and passing because they don't care
they're not interested who would see
these videos and think oh my God I can't
believe so I kind of like that the Deep
fake thing I kind of like because it
means that all these gotcha scandals are
just over that's true because you think
okay I can't trust any of these videos
all these distractions and maybe that
would be a positive thing yeah like
literally not trusting anything yeah
because then I'll do my own I love
though you you put into chat gbt you say
uh what are five things white people can
improve on it's just this that is that
so what are five things black people can
improve on it's like how dare you and
they give you like it's not even like
they don't answer or they can't give you
an answer they give you a disclaimer
like you're a terrible person you're
asking that yeah exactly yeah okay
you're up okay
let's be honest and Michael's none
loophole aside if somebody is not
married by the age of 30 it's them
oh so it's saying about religious life
it could be a consecrated single or a
religious or something but put that
aside for a second if you're the kind of
person who would marry and you don't get
married by 30 it's on you
I think there can be some Nuance I think
in many many cases
like I think about my oldest brother
I've talked about with my brothers now
he's not married he's 34. but he's
choosing not to be pisses me off he's
choosing not to because he wants to be a
celibate or excuse me not to be because
he's just just because he you know I
don't know he's not he's not getting
married he's not getting married yeah
buddy you know I also look at friends
who are desperately trying who are very
very intentional with it and I you know
a couple of good friends that are like
mid-20s and are very very worried about
that who are like very deeply and they
like are trying and I do think that you
know kind of some of it will come down
to you know how much are you putting
yourself out there and you say that you
are you're not being you know genuine
with it or you're altering yourself to
try to fit into somebody else's idea
what I don't I think it can be a lot of
things but I also know that like the
dating landscape these days is
disgusting yeah it's disgusting there's
no there because the standards and Norms
were destroyed by the libs in the 60s
and 70s no one knows what to expect
people now say we're talking we're at
different talking stages right you're
talking you don't even know what you
can't even call it dating there's a new
article
but it was talking about gen Z's
love of situationships and how it's okay
and how gen Z should kind of like settle
in this situations ship phase and the
talking phase and how that's really
positive Frozen adolescence yes right so
I do think that a lot of it is because
of people's choices that they're making
but also how much of that is directly
from them and how much of that is from
like these social right you know
societal changes that we've had that
makes it impossible if you're if you're
a woman you're raised in a liberal
environment and you were taught a bunch
of nonsense yeah and then you were told
don't have serious relationships don't
ever Choose Love and Marriage over your
career you've got to go get some
Advanced degree to go work in the widget
Factory or study you know some super
specific nonsense to not get a job
teaching at a university and then you
end up and you look up you finally got
all your degrees you got all your
spreadsheets are done and you're 30 and
you think oh I was lied to yeah oh you
know is it the person's fault yeah at a
certain point you gotta personal
responsibility right but it's also the
whole culture everything in the culture
your parents your for school your
popular entertainment your the
scientists the everything has been lying
to you and so it takes one person to be
you're raised in that environment and
then to say no I'm not going to so I
think it is a balanced skill but in many
cases I do think that you know people
cause their own problems so yeah it's
true you know that's when people say
I've got all you know a thousand failed
relationships
there's a common denominator if you
haven't really dated and you've been
like very particular or you've been
focused on something else I'm like okay
that's probably something else but if
you're just
it is more likely
that Joe Biden threatened a black
gangster at a pool after children rubbed
his legs then that Joe Biden's father
saw two dudes kissing in 1961 and said
it's simple Joe they love each other
so they've clarified here yes for Corn
Pop is more likely no for gay curious
great rampant Joes more likely how did
they describe yeah I want to read this
again yeah
they just love each other Joey yeah
that's what happens in nineteen fifties
Scranton yeah yeah or even earlier
probably 19. so you're answering as I
would answer yeah yes more likely the
gangster
for sure do you know why why
I hate to admit this because I'm sure
Joe made up pretty much all of the
details yeah
Corn Pop is real
there was there was a local newspaper
article someone dug it up of this guy
yeah who was called Corn Pop who existed
around the time in around the place as
Joe Biden I that part at least of the
story is real I hope the kids rubbing
his hairy legs is not real that probably
is real too so I guess Joe Biden
actually of all the stories he's ever
told that one might be the most truthful
I mean it's just like
it's not even a clever that other one
where it's you know my you know
grandfather what is it his was it his
dad his father yes that sounds exactly
like the libs on Twitter that are like
my daughter came to my room I was like
and I was like no we cried we cried in
the TSA agents applauded yes yes it was
in the middle of every you know do you
know what would happen if a couple guys
started making out on the street in
Delaware or Scranton in the 50s
don't want to know we don't want him
yeah it would not be nice yeah okay all
right
I admit I do sympathize with that Dylan
Mulvaney because I too was once an
impressionable theater kid and who knows
what could have happened to me if I was
cast into rent on Broadway in my wayward
youth
Matt Stone's version where the the laid
song was everyone has AIDS my uncle and
my dog okay um so you said that I
sympathize with don't Mulberry because I
was a theater kid uh
yeah of course yeah there but for the
grace of God go I
you know I talk about this a lot I and
it's I don't it's not exactly Dylan but
I do see myself in a lot of the young
women who transition yeah who went
through a terrible puberty and didn't
fit in and felt like and I always say
the ugly duckling I was the ugly
duckling I was like gangly and I wasn't
cute definitely not at like 12 years old
and you know that kind of thing I
desperately you know wanted to be
friends with more guys I hated the girls
when I was around super like that would
have been me if I had not had the mother
that I did and she literally had a
conversation with me and I remember we
were on Mulholland Drive and I was about
15 years old and she was like I want you
to think very critically about how
you're presenting yourself to the world
because you were all black you're
wearing Doc Martens you're sitting like
a dude like this you only hang out with
men you're angry at women and she was
like it's okay to be feminine without
getting rid of the parts of your
personality that make you more of a
tomboy that come with being raised
around three brothers and she was like I
see you going down a path it's not you
and it's something that's coming out of
anger and resentment and not feeling
like you fit in with the more like
promiscuous and shallow La girls or
whatever but that doesn't that's not
everyone doesn't mean you're not a girl
yeah so it's not exactly Dylan but I do
sympathize with that kind of thing of
you know you feel so out of place and
this culture only feeds you two options
which is to be like the stereotypical
whatever or it's like oh if you're
uncomfortable with yourself just change
it you'll be so happy yeah yeah I know
plus theater just makes everything more
complicated it does it does because I I
was fortunate in that doing theater was
was only one part of my life you know I
did I I was involved in lots of other
stuff too in high school and student
government and all these things so it
kind of balanced out a little bit of
that but I my fear would not be that I
would have become a chick or something
or a homosexual right you know for all
of my many sins yes I always knew I was
a guy and I always liked girls uh but
my fear would have been that I would
have followed the Dylan Mulvaney route
to just
seek attention above all things yeah
yeah which you see a lot which you see a
lot and entertainment look I I have a
show I give speeches I go around so it's
not that I I'm averse to people paying
attention to things I say but it's
it's different if that's the primary
thing you're seeking you're going to go
down a dark path if that's secondary to
I want to say something that's true I
want to learn something about human
nature I want to help people see the
world more precisely you know and you
get attention for that and that helps
the work that's a wonderful thing but if
you were just chasing you will do
anything then you will do anything
including you know yeah well he hasn't
done that yet has he not done that no of
course no because he's normalizing the
bolts remember that video no
I don't remember that video oh you
should watch it yeah he did a little
dance where he was normalized he wore
very very tight shorts and he normalized
the Bulge could I request a spoon to
carve out my mind's eye from that image
okay
in a well-ordered society crusty white
dogs would be slotted into their proper
place Outdoors among the squirrels
raccoons and pit bulls
and babies I hate you wow crusty little
white dogs
hmm
uh well I want to say
yeah cause you're a good man
I think you have to drink I'm afraid to
say I've been drinking the entire time I
know I don't know yeah I don't it's not
I haven't met Rocky I have not met Rocky
that's true maybe he'll be the one but
he can change
Rocky yes there's a girl she didn't have
to Rocky Balboa get it right who is a
male
you know what she
she's fixed so oh she's a eunuch of a
dog she's a she's a non-binary dog now I
it's not that I hate dogs
I'm not a dog person I'm not a cat
person I'm much more of a people person
but I do think if one is going to have a
dog yeah a dog has to be either
comically small like a wiener dog or
sort of comically you know deformed like
a bulldog like an English okay yeah I do
love Bulldogs yep or inconveniently
large that's true like a Saint Bernard
Great Dane kind of thing and you know
what I prefer bigger dogs we always had
bigger dogs that you know I had a
Bernese mountain dog and then my dog
that I had for 16 years he died in
August was a great Pyrenees my mom has
well right now she has 10 Great Pyrenees
she had puppies but she really she
really always wow
but I had a friend that I worked with at
Trader Joe's and his family had a
accidental litter of puppies and he
needed to find homes for them and he was
like I know that you know you love dogs
can I can I give you this little like
floof yeah and I was in a mid-college
crisis what is what I would call it my
sophomore year of college I don't know
why I decided to adopt a dog sophomore
year college oh my goodness well I was I
wasn't like living in dorms or anything
like that just like sure bring it on but
he wanted to be a boxer he was working
at Trader Joe's but he was wanting to be
a boxer so I was like I need to name
this like little female dog after a
boxer Rocky yeah I love Rocky little
Evander Holyfield yeah that's not as
cute for a dog no not at all but my
other dog he is bigger
he's a real dog
is not
he's not inconveniently large Rocky is a
she's not a she's not a dog she's a
she's in a subset of you know she's in
her own category she's a trans she is
she's something she's non-binary yeah
okay okay
ah
99 of men who are pro-choice hold that
view so that random swipe rights are
more likely to hook up so they won't be
on the hook for child support
[Music]
let's answer and I'll
foreign
Yes except that last part I I do yes
they say they're pro-abortion because
they want to women to sleep with them I
don't think it's primarily so that it'll
be easier to kill their children if a
child is is I don't think it goes that
deep it doesn't go that deep I think
it's because they think that that's what
women want yeah and they'll they'll say
whatever but I also do think I don't
think it goes as deep as like child
support but I do think they don't want
the responsibility I mean it's the same
thing of why they're hooking up rather
than trying to pursue a relationship
because that actually takes commitment
and effort right and emotionally putting
yourself out there right so I do think
that it comes with a lack of you know
wanting to be responsible for anything
so maybe it would lead into that but I
don't think they're looking at that like
oh I don't you know I don't wanna
whatever these men they're just chasing
304s you know yeah I learned that phrase
on the whatever podcast
it's it I just said yes if you typed in
304 in a calculator and read it upside
down
five
eight zero zero eight
my brother used to do that I was
of course
anti-disestablishmentarianism of course
yeah uh I didn't at first but after
watching his viral would you rather clip
on attractive men who are now trans
women
I think Andrew Tate is probably having
more fun in the Romanian prison than we
first thought
he says that he he insinuates that he
would rather but he would sleep with a
hot trans guy girl guy yeah guys a less
attractive than a less attractive woman
who presents oh
apparently
it's never your right time he's tweeting
yes
I haven't no I haven't kept up he always
said that he was bold by choice when you
see that picture he's not bought by
choice he's yeah it's a little
unfortunate wow it's a little patchy all
right just be honest
okay
real talk
dish girl right yeah let's build a tea
real talk people who claim to have been
abducted or had Direct contact with
aliens were most likely just tripping
balls on a dose of the old Joe Rogan
special
what is Matt taking
yeah
right yeah Matt does confound this a
little bit
no they might just be mentally ill or
vexed by demons yeah I don't think it
has to be drugs or they're confused or
they just don't know they might have
thought that it was yeah they could be
gullible I see blinking weird things in
the sky all the time yeah and like
yeah listen I wake up in the middle of
the night and I think that I'm being
probed by a little green man you know
and uh but I think oh it was probably
just you know a light Breeze or
something for your child yeah get out of
my room buddy okay
it is more difficult for women over six
feet to find a date than it is for a guy
who is under five eight so it's more
difficult for a woman oh over away
because so many guys like really tall
girls Yeah well yeah well because
they're like oh I like God my I don't
know that's true I mean that's true if
you're like six five it's I imagine that
is harder you know but I mean it could
work out for you because you'll date
some NBA player and you'll be super rich
that's true you make a good point no yes
it's certainly true it's very hard for
because I think men are more willing
what goes back to that whole thing of
you know women control sexual encounters
women are the Gateway quite literally
yeah but men are more willing to
compromise on that kind of thing and
they're like oh just she's beautiful
whatever I don't care and women will
look at a great guy and be like there
was a guy I was gonna he has a very
funny nickname from this town that I
hung out in growing up and but I I'm not
going to say his name because he would
be identifiable you know to people in
this community and so I'm not going to
say it was trust me it was very very
funny in a great pun and he but he was
quite sure he was there's something
medical going on and he was very angry
about it you know and I think people
carry a lot of that anger you know the
Napoleon complex or something but the
thing is if you can
just accept one state in life and if
you're a guy who's under five eight or
something and then you marry a really
tall woman you're gonna look like the
man yeah it'll look like Sarkozy or
something it all comes back to
confidence yeah if you are comfortable
with it if you're not trying to
overcompensate or anything like that
yeah totally yeah okay
all righty we're getting to the end here
I have a ghost story
yeah
we'll get it together yeah
that do you
I mean I I thought that I did when I was
like eight years but I don't know so the
two things that I think I saw uh my
grandfather my paternal grandfather died
when I was very young and I thought that
I saw him at my grandmother's house
shortly after he passed and then I got
really into it and was like Mom can you
like
to ghost or whatever and I would have
like seances in my kitchen dining table
not like not real seances but I would
like I lit a candle at like eight years
old and was like okay I guess I need to
try to talk to Granddad because he's
like anyway it was so stupid I don't
know why I was such a freak I was so
weird
um you know what they are because there
have been plenty of stories where I it
seems like you know it there's something
that would seem to reflect one's dead
grandfather or something like that I've
got plenty of those
uh but then the question is is it a
ghost
is it a hallucination
a ghost imagination or a demon
we all get back to Demons here it does
and it's a it's actually a real Catholic
Protestant thing some Protestants
believe in ghosts but a lot of
Protestants don't this is what Hamlet is
about in the opening scene right you
know the question is did I see the ghost
of my father and Hamlet is largely about
the Protestant Revolution you know the
University of Wittenberg and
the nature of Truth and is there
Monopoly on truth anymore and so the the
question of have I seen a ghost is a
question of are the Catholics writer of
the Protestants right in many ways and
uh
but the the argument
for ghosts existing is there's a ghost
in the Bible yeah the witch event or
summons a ghost of Samuel and uh so I
think ghosts can exist but I don't if I
if something gets a little bit eerie and
often you think I just don't
look too into it yeah I just think
there's a lot of spiritual stuff going
on all around me I don't it's not for me
curiosity is not a virtue yep as father
rehill told me on a long interview well
I'm pretty sure my father saw a ghost as
well because I used to sleep in my
parents bedroom I would like run across
the house because well I was always here
they may get into demons here but we
lived in a very very long House in
Chattanooga Tennessee and it was like
all one level but it was super long I
had like one bedroom Wing here and then
my parents had almost here and I would
like turn off the lights and Sprint
because I was like certain that there
was like some crazy woman chasing me I
also had a dream of like
a small person this was a recurring
dream chasing me and being able to like
it was like a ghost of a small person
like teleporting around and like chasing
me so anyway it's like a five foot six
guy he was like I want to be your
husband get over here
small little like Asian tiny 411 and
black and red chasing me anyway so I
like was very very weird but I would run
into my parents room anyway so one night
when I was sleeping my father thinks
that he saw the ghost of my brother who
had passed away like three years prior
like standing next to my bed and yeah
very weird
yeah like I'll do ghost tours will you
the one in Franklin it's really good
well everything's haunted around here I
know you were reminded me though yeah
there was one time
I woke up and I'm
I'm pretty sure I saw her felt a ghost
and you don't know because you think
well you're waking up but you don't kind
of look you just think okay yeah okay
you're right this is the last one that's
you this is me yeah
people who believe the Earth is the
center of the universe should kick rocks
and go touch grass
I'm kicking a rock it's a center of the
universe over here Ben Davies
okay wait people who believe the Earth
is the center of the universe kick rocks
and go touch grass they're crazy
is it metaphorically or like do you
actually like is it somebody who
actually believes what's a metaphor
that's a metaphor man
[Music]
the Earth is the center of universe okay
more precisely man is the center of the
universe okay and is this like physic or
physically or are we just talking about
I mean what is
it literal I don't know literal refers
to letters which are some symbols you
know
all models are wrong
some models are useful so this model
that we have whatever model you have of
the physical Universe yeah let's say it
derives from some conception of the Big
Bang it involves the Earth circling the
sun around the Milky Way and the various
galaxies and superclusters that were
floating all around
whatever image you have in your mind is
wrong right it's not even close to it
yeah
even the visible Universe which is every
single thing you're imagining right now
is something like five percent of the
University so according to whatever
model which is probably wrong too
so all models are wrong some models are
useful what tells you more about reality
that man is some random little blip
floating on a rock somewhere in the
middle of nowhere for no particular
reason at all or
man is the center of the universe
because what I can tell you for certain
is that man
a rational being a union of body and
soul and a hylomorphic union is at the
meeting of
metaphysical reality and physical
reality I know that for sure that's the
only that's the only reason we can speak
right now
so I I can rely on that
therefore if I
view the universe as with the Earth at
the center of it
you can come up with a mathematical
model as to why that's true yeah it's
old we're all just talking about models
and it will tell you much more about the
nature of reality it's kind of like
what's a woman people don't really have
a good answer for that people say well
uh 2x chromosomes two I don't know what
the hell 2x chromosomes is what does
that mean that doesn't mean anything to
me what is a woman sugar spice and
everything nice I get that that tells me
a lot more sugar spice and everything
nice is much closer to what a woman is
than two x girls tangible we can see it
we experience it every day yeah rather
than I guess yeah that I'm seeing your
point right rather than something that
we're just not truly understanding what
we're taking from an expert right yeah
with some expert who doesn't know
anything who's got all these wrong
priors and premises you know who doesn't
who thinks that he's the center of the
universe like Mr patchy or somebody yeah
but no maybe you've convinced me maybe
maybe here we are Brett you and me right
at the center of the universe this is
the most important thing in the world
and you know I mean even it's very
important too for like sacramental
theology because the idea of the Blessed
Sacrament is it's the perfect union of
physical and metaphysical I mean this
this idea that the cross is the axle on
which the World Turns that tells me much
more than some stupid science lecture on
magnets at the North Pole but it's not
even it's not really at the pole it's
like kind of the fake poll and yeah
whatever man whatever nerd I'm gonna I
care about truth all right yep and I
there's a lot more truth in uh poetry
and myth and Revelation and the true
myth in fact then in whatever some
stupid lecture Dr patchy gave that's why
you learn more from literature and
stories than you do anywhere else of
course of course that's why emotion is
more important than convincing people
yes and and you know where else people
find truth sometimes in vino veritas
they will sometimes say though I don't
know sometimes they get deluded there as
well cheers my dear to your health to
your sobriety
into my sobriety I'll next time I'll
drink triple after Easter wonderful to
have you thank you wonderful to have you
we'll see you next time on yes or no
foreign